you don't look that excited you don't
look that excited Wow when you hold
hands with Nina be prepared to have your
hand squeeze half a day seven believe
nation today we're going to Corfu
[Music]
so for those you've been following along
we're on a European trip we've had some
crazy weather the past couple days last
night finally was better little rocky
but way better than for its that's a
good news I did about a cough means I'm
gonna sneeze
it's a crazy sneeze attack yeah let you
feel why no no you're super sick I have
I have a cough and a fever Nina is a
crazy sneeze fest 18 seasons in a row
then has her phone on the floor okay
we're gonna go to car food only gonna
eat and then car food
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Nina's getting sick we thought it okay
my coffee they say only miss nipple and
the snip oh we heard it
listen I like the stubbornness you're a
stubborn Chinese person we love you just
a car wreck all right there
so Corfu is one of the most famous
islands in Greece visited frequently on
most cruise ship destinations
it's an old city small town and it's
protected by unesco world heritage site
because it's a medieval city so we're
gonna explore the city and get our first
stop being accomplished our famous
coffee shop ready
[Music]
go get it
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey Nina we're going to a very famous
restaurant Nina in Corfu very famous
restaurant famous for their seafood
we're going you ready for some seafood
you don't look that excited you don't
look that excited wow you know a lot of
research went into this
let's see some excited Nina yay this
white building here should be it yeah
this shemitah
found it
[Music]
guys look what Nina can do with her
elbows no dude the thing with your arm
the other arm you're leaning
you're leaning through the thing you're
lean with your elbow in put it like
against the table I just cracked my
shoulder now put your right arm against
it sit there that's that's kind of nasty
right
hey thankfully vation can you do with
your fingers to look how far back you
bend your fingers right ah like crazy
like bend my finger back guys look I got
bitten by spider to it see look at
something something I got bitten by
something you sweet blood all right
let's get Nina her soup so there's a
very famous restaurant right next to the
fish market so if you're here you have
to have fish so we're doing the seafood
seafood spaghetti Bibi octopus Bibi
calamari and their specialty fish soup
[Music]
Wow is a good reaction yeah I love it
all right Nina go for it baby calamari
this is the best I can either try this
first okay spaghetti also hot also good
nice
two thumbs up all right the unexpected
bonus dessert came he designed them he
loved sweets
that's sarcastic by the way
okay okay what is it
Fred okay Wow bread okay okay all right
are we doing Nina okay very full very
nice food very nice man yeah very nice
purse to give us free a lot of what
energy yeah Nina does not have a lot of
energy right now Nina wants to pass out
right she's tired not because she's sick
she's drowsy coughing sneezing not
because she's sick just because she's
you know right just cuz she slept eight
hours last night she's not sick though
this is just on vacation and that's what
happens on vacation right right exactly
exactly so we're gonna go back to the
boat I'm not gonna sleep because I have
to make videos for you guys have to make
videos and then probably have a quick
nap before we go for dinner okay let's
go yeah why am i squeezing your hand so
tight it's really tight my hands hurting
too when you hold hands with Nina be
prepared to have your hand squeeze your
hand for awesomeness that you attained
purple purple is royalty you know that
the color of royalty yeah now your
princess Kara Michael Nina what do you
think that's my that's my reason I think
it's great
okay back to the boat
[Music]
so today is the last day to do filming
I'm meeting Cristina tomorrow she's
gotta take all the footage off my camera
because Dropbox on the Internet the
cruise ship is not fantastic I've been
putting this off I've been waiting for
the right weather waiting for the right
temperature reading for the waiting for
the right angle scenery not to feel sick
but how's it happened having fight the
perfect time so I just got to do it so
I'm filming the next round the videos
probably already happening this channel
by the time you see this here in my
cruise ship cabin because not making
videos is not an option so even if I
have to lie that in bed but like hey
believe nation I'm gonna do it and
putting it off for the past couple days
couldn't find the perfect time and so
now is the perfect time there's always
the perfect time to do the thing that
you need to do to move your business
forward so here we go video-time know
who you are over to you Oprah Winfrey
okay filming is done I'm I have more
energy and that is it before that the
filming brought out a ton of positive
energy and me I'm sharing in a crash
sharing in a crash in in the next half
hour so but Nina Nene how you doing back
there how was it sitting in on my film
session yeah you're in all of them yeah
in the background people are gonna leave
comments for sure I scared Nina the
first time I'm very loud listen I have
nothing lot loud this is important it's
good to be loud it's important to be
loud she was standing right in front of
me and I and I pulled out my phone and
said a film a lot and was our first line
hey I start them what's that believe
nation it's over and Nina wasn't fright
in front of me she got she got scared
Nina we love you
next time you should do the videos you
guys want Nina in a bikini video right
to do one video herself what they want
to see you Nina people want to see you
always got all the comments on this
channel when you make an appearance
okay what do we do next we're gonna
relax and then go for dinner you okay
how's your sickness good love you Nina
[Music]
okay I'm still feeling great after the
video that was a secret just have to
make more videos sooner that was the
secret they don't feel better
oh they opened like the open up the door
yeah it's not blocked up from the wind
anymore yeah yeah weathers get better
we're off to dinner it is elegant night
so you can see how elegant
I am and Nina and inna also has retained
shoes because the past two times we've
gone dancing they were super random we
just happen to walking through there
playing salsa
that's what Nina's for students and her
sandals which is doable but flip-flops
but is very difficult to do turns on
singles so then we go and get the shoes
in vain believes it's happened twice so
she's prepared and has her sandals I
didn't mean her dance shoes so just in
case we see the music band we're gonna
dance yeah keep going
here we go dinner tonight dinner
no it's the other group very sad it's
not the salsa group oh it's just a deep
none now see other groups all right what
do you think Nina next time good thing
you got your shoes
[Music]
try the soup
my suit okay give it a shot Nina
learn
all the wines Vanina
just making me carry one all right we're
headed back to the cabin you guys are
not invited we've got some homework to
do Nina's helping me write one of the
two books that I have you're gonna help
me well through the exercise she's gonna
help me okay yeah it's gonna happen okay
it's a homework to be okay homework to
do tonight no what no no you're not
playing games something you gotta work
gotta work you got a your your story
will inspire millions of people it's
gonna happen if you want to see what we
did yesterday and how we got massively
sick check out the video next to us I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe I'll see you there
yummy if I can get through this it makes
you stronger